[Musique]
Halloween et ses costumes effrayants ont
défaire les tout le week-end sur les
réseaux sociaux brand pour d'autres le
31 octobre c'est l'occasion de rebondir
sur une actualité de l'année comme par
exemple le navire qui a bloqué le canal
de Suède aujourd'hui la fête est finie
et il y en a une qui attendait cela avec
un patience Mariah Carey le sait bien en
ce premier novembre on n'a jamais été
aussi proche de Noël et regardez cette
image
Twitter enfin poster sur Instagram par
Kylian Mbappe et pour Halloween alors
Rago alors non là c'est pas le
MP c'était juste avant voilà même si
nous pensons à commémorer nos défunts à
prier pour eux et à visiter les tombes
de nos familles
nous sommes d'abord invités à la joie et
à l'espoir d'une vie nouvelle tout le
week-end des streamers les streamers les
plus connus tient d'ailleurs le français
était réuni pour le the event d'un
événement caritatif sur trois jours à
Montpellier Michou inoxtag Gotaga
Domingo aussi vous les connaissez pas
les jeunes les connaissent par cœur ils
étaient en direct depuis des ordinateurs
à Montpellier leurs abonnés les regarder
en temps réel en faisant des dons
[Musique]
pour vérifier que c'était le bon chiffre
au programme des parties de jeux vidéo
bien sûr mais les participants ont comme
à chaque fois redoubler d'imagination
pour faire rire ou surprendre leur
communauté quelle est la capitale du Sri
Lanka
ça je l'ai pas encore testé du tout
attention
c'est vraiment terrible de perdre
ne te casse pas la nuque
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on dirait
une petite ressemblance 10 millions
d'euros 10 millions d'euros récoltés
pour action contre la fin avec en prime
les félicitations d'Emmanuel Macron
c'est un record né en 2016-20 avait
permis de récolter un peu plus de 170
000 euros 6 ans plus tard il est plus
que jamais l'événement caritatif le plus
lucratif sur twitch
la cop26 à Glasgow les grandes secondes
se retrouvent pour tenter de maîtriser
la hausse moyenne des températures pas
le sujet ça sert vraiment à quelque
chose c'est grand Raoult c'est grand
Raoult pardon et notamment présent à ce
sommet de la dernière chance le prince
Charles qui comme ses homologues va tout
faire pour éviter de se prendre les
pieds dans le tapis
[Musique]
et le chiffre du jour 474
soyez sympa
aussi et borico ont certainement
contribué à démocratiser le vin dans la
Ligue américaine
néanmoins que l'Institut National du
Cancer recommande de ne pas dépasser un
litre et demi non pardon un verre et
demi ça c'est pour moi
allez très bien
pour les autres un vernis seulement par
repas ou par jour par jour le roi
d'Ecosse se fait mettre au tapis vert
l'Écosse donc ça me fait penser à la
mérite puisque c'est les îles en
Amérique centrale je crois que
destructions
[Musique]
c'est sûr c'est pas explosion
et regardez elle est là ma petite beauté
chérie
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
je me sens très bien je suis heureuse on
a passé une belle nuit oui on va dire
que c'était intense oui je m'attendais
pas que ça arrive aussi vite quand c'est
vrai que en fait moi il m'a dit je suis
prêt je crois que j'ai été j'étais très
bon
tu m'as dit qu'il y avait
[Musique]
cette paix que les membres de
l'Assemblée partagent ici dans la
cathédrale Saint-Paul à Liège nous voilà
dressons également chers auditeurs et
téléspectateurs d'où que vous nous
suiviez que cette paix du Seigneur vous
garde et vous accompagne tout au long de
cette semaine
et puis le même Charles je suis désolé
parle moins fort une voix d'homme c'est
quelqu'un qui est sûr de ce qu'il dit on
avait une idée de la virilité très
monodimensionnelle il fallait être
costaud physique il fallait tout le
temps un homme maintenant on se dit que
c'est plutôt est-ce qu'on sait s'occuper
ce préoccuper des autres prendre
accepter assumer la responsabilité
envers les autres c'est plutôt cela
d'être un homme
aussi joli déhanché comme un cheval
ah ouais
je sais pas quel groupe je préfère là
[Rires]
j'ai tapé sur un moteur de recherche
j'ai les pieds qui et pas de surprise à
entendre dire que sur je les pieds qui
puent pardonner mon vocabulaire docteur
c'est comme ça et puis on trouve j'ai
les pieds qui gonflent qui pèlent comme
Jean-Louis aussi ou encore je l'ai Piqué
qui me brûle en tout cas la recherche
j'ai les pieds qui puent ça génère un
million 300000 résultats sur le web
c'est le mal du siècle apparemment donc
Jean-Louis a bien fait de m'écrire ça va
servir à beaucoup de monde et du coup
vous avez demandé la vie d'un
spécialiste des champignons l'engouement
de la cueillette ne doit pas faire
oublier que la prudence est mère de
toutes les vertus cette année plus de
330 intoxication déjà été enregistrées
en France dont trois mortels et on
referme ses actualités avec ce message à
caractère informatif je suis désolé mais
on a du temps de parole à rattraper
comment dirais-je
merci beaucoup Jean-Marie Le Pen